[Music]
the loud house has some very interesting
characters and we'd love to watch the
family grow up have you ever wondered
what Lisa and Lily loud would look like
at 16 just wait until you see Lynne with
brand new hair don't forget to subscribe
to our channel and give this video a big
thumbs up let's check out the loud house
characters reimagined as 16 years old
Louann loud the 14 year old Lou a and
loud is definitely one of our favorite
loud kids
she's a prankster and a jokester who
just loves to play around with her
siblings here is a 16 year old version
of Louann made by C Bart from deviantART
we rarely see Louann with her hair down
but she does have her iconic yellow
outfits that will never go out of style
here's another version of a slightly
older Louann created by bunny absent
eeeh this version might not have the
iconic yellow outfit but she still looks
totally adorable looks like Louann went
through Lola's closet and grabbed those
adorable pink slippers the next
illustration belongs to s b99 stuff from
deviantART and this Luanne also doesn't
look that much older and she's
definitely sticking to her style
Lily loud we talked a lot about the loud
house on this YouTube channel but we
never mentioned the baby of the family
Lily loud is just 15 months old and it's
hard to predict her personality or the
traits she'll develop as she grows older
see Bart did an awesome job in showing
what Lily could potentially look like as
a 16 year old
she looks very similar to Lori and Lenny
we really do wonder what kind of
characteristics will she have at 16
here's another version of Lily this one
belongs to Anton dis from deviantART
doesn't she look totally adorable in her
schoolgirl outfit we can't wait to see
Lily grow up and adjust to her life with
10 older siblings what do you think
she'll look like at 16 Lauri loud Lauri
might be the oldest sibling of the loud
family and she loves to rub it in
everyone's faces Lauri 17 so she's only
one year older but we'll still show you
a couple of different versions of what
she looked like at 16 as always the
talented see Bart did an amazing job
Lorri is usually not interested in the
usual kiddie stuff her siblings are into
but see Bart's show
with an adorable smile Cruella De Vil 84
also illustrated the typical Laurie look
we love Marcus fan Griffin showed us
what Laurie would look like just chillin
on the beach and enjoying her life if
you want to see Laurie reimagined as a
bodybuilder or a boy make sure you watch
our other loud house videos blonde aloud
the six year old Lana has a tough job of
being the twin of her polar opposite
sister Lola the two get along and we
totally love that Lana's stands out from
the crowd and prefers to stick to her
tomboy nature let's check out if the 16
year old Lana still prefers to be a
tomboy here's C Bart's version doesn't
she remind you of windy from gravity
falls she definitely looks much older
the loud house club on deviantART also
reimagined an older version of Lana we
loved her signature red snapback here's
another version by Jay boy 32x his
illustration of the 16 year old Lana is
slightly different she looks way taller
and it looks like she's got some muscles
from all the tinkering she's been doing
around the house we can definitely see
you Lana getting strong as she grows
older Louie loud fifteen-year-old Luna
is one of our favorites she stands out
from the rest of the kids with her
rockin style that's hard to replace we'd
love that when she hums songs of some of
our favorite artists if you watch our
videos you've seen her reimagined as
many different alternative versions so
let's have a look at what she looked
like just a year older C bard stuck to
Lunas original style but gave her a new
version of her purple outfit one of our
favorite illustrations is sv 99 stuffs
belly dancing version of Luna she looks
like she's ready to rock her hips and
equally as impressive is this next level
illustration by wrongs of one two three
four from her swirly earrings to her
detailed hair doesn't she look totally
awesome
Lucy loud the loud house definitely has
some of the most unique characters ever
we love every single personality we see
on the show because it shows us that is
definitely okay to be yourself no matter
how eccentric your style or personality
is Lucy loud is one of those characters
that reminds us it's okay to feel Moody
she's just eight but she's definitely
relatable across all
yes here's what see Bart from deviantART
thinks Lucy would look like at 16 she
certainly looks adorable with longer
hair a headband and a dark dress
Henny loc 57 Illustrated her in a
slightly different way as a 16 year old
it seems like her bangs are getting
longer and longer
Lucy is without a doubt a popular
character to illustrate and we can't
wait to see even more versions of her
look Lola loud we've previously
mentioned that the six year old pageant
princess reminds us of Alana Thompson
from here comes honey boo boo the two
share a lot of characteristics and their
personalities definitely match so here's
how the six-year-old Lola would grow up
if it were up to the talented deviantart
artists see bard made her wear an iconic
pink outfit but she certainly looks
older in fact doesn't she remind you of
Lenny and Lauri Amos 19 Illustrated her
in an even more fabulous way after all a
pageant queen is always a pageant queen
and our favorite is this adorable
illustration which belongs to stress she
looks like a Disney Princess it looks
like a low low but becomes slightly more
graceful than the diva character we know
today Lisa loud it's hard to pick a
favorite character from the loud house
when it's full of so many unique
personalities Lisa might be only four
years old but she's incredibly
intelligent for her age and she's
definitely smarter than all her family
members combined she's known for wearing
her large glasses and her green sweater
but here's what this four-year-old would
look like at 16 see Bart's illustration
shows she'd still rock the glasses and
her green sweater but she definitely
looks taller and here's been the looneys
version which shows the iconic Lisa look
we all know and love the art Trix took
it to a new level with this amazing
illustration of an older Lisa we totally
see her in a lab outfit probably
creating another portal between the two
cartoon worlds Lincoln loud it's hard to
be the only boy in the family but it's
even harder when you have 10 other
sisters that can easily get on your
nerves Lincoln has a unique look and
he's the only child with
here but if you want to know why his
hair is the way it is you'll have to
watch some of our other videos here's
the 11 year old Lincoln at 16 see Bart
from deviantART did an awesome job with
this one he's dressed according to his
age he's got more hair and we can still
see his chips tooth Cole Han 3000 gave
us this adorable version of a slightly
older Lincoln and as a bonus here's
sugar elements illustration of Lincoln's
entire growing up timeline doesn't he
look awesome
we love Lincoln Lin loud if you have
siblings you probably have some
competitive members of your family or
maybe you're the one that likes to make
a competition out of everything the 13
year old Lin loud is exactly the same on
top of that she loves sports and loves
to win at just about anything here's C
Bart's version of Lin at 16 with her
hair down but still in her sporty outfit
SB 99 stuff also kept her outfit but
made her slightly taller here's another
illustration by the same artist this
time in different mid action shots
Rainey got me on deviantART ditch Lin's
original hair and gave her a brand new
look we love Lin with dark hair and
light blue clothing we bet this 13 year
old will continue to be competitive no
matter how old she gets that's it for
the loud house characters reimagined as
16 year olds for more videos like this
one check out the loud house reimagined
as kids teenagers adults and parents see
you next time
[Music]